in an interview John Goodman suggested
that in the spin-off show the Connors
Roseanne's character will be dead is
gonna be dead yeah so finally a funeral
Trump will be allowed to attend
speaking of Trump it's been reported
that president Trump's relationship with
Jeff Sessions is quote beyond repair
yeah apparently the relationship is so
bad and awkward Trump now refers to
sessions as Melania 57 year old Eddie
Murphy 57 year old Eddie Murphy's about
to become a dad for the tenth time even
more impressive it turns out that all
ten of his kids are being played by
Eddie Murphy very talented fellow a
California mother true story a
California mother has decided to donate
fifteen thousand ounces of her breast
milk here's here's the disturbing part -
Starbucks
know what pumpkin spice press milk now
Andy you're the man of the hour tonight
this is your special chance to read
maybe the final monologue joke if you'd
like to deliver it would you like to do
glass I'd love to Conan all right we'll
take a crack here we go okay he's going
to be okay but a man's private parts
were injured when his east cigarette
exploded in his pocket on the plus side
the man is now officially Jewish
[Applause]
you